we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
caller concerned about what a trump
Budaj edge general election would be
like take a listen hi david love the
show
I was just wondering so hypothetically
if Pete mutagens were to win the
nomination somehow do you think that he
would be able to hold his own against
Trump I kind of don't think so you know
I think that he has proven himself to be
unable to face harsh criticism
especially you know look at the
criticism that he received from Chloe
Shar
you know declaring victory before Iowa
was officially called and so on
he's very milquetoast and I just think
that frankly Trump would fry him like an
egg on the sidewalk I just wanted to get
your take on that so listen here's the
thing the debates are never as one-sided
as people imagine that they're going to
be in advance of the Trump Hillary
debates many of us thought Trump doesn't
know anything about policy and Hillary
knows so much she's gonna crush him and
I believe she won every debate on
substance but there's always so much
more to it and the perception of these
debates very often is everybody thinks
the person they're planning to vote for
one you've got so many exceptions you've
got enlightened people who say I'm
voting for a but be sort of got the
better of the debate I share with you
concerns about what the dynamic will be
between Trump and some of the other
candidates but it will never be as
lopsided and one-sided as we predict
because there are so many people who are
going to see the debates through hyper
partisan lenses so we'll see what it's
like but it's not going to be the way
this caller is suggesting if you
disagree with me let me know we've got a
great bonus show for you today
become a member or patron to get instant
access